and both filly and David fist is there
and here's Makura again coming up with a
steal this Dale was London - the motion
on the alley-oop from bacon to miles
bridges dwayne bacon lifting it two
bridges who finishes time out in Vegas
let's see if they can get back and as we
see him explode down the lane now he's a
lefty but he dunks it with his right
hand and and this is again about his
athleticism about take cram quickly gets
inside
[Applause]
and flex on at the
[Applause]
well the organization give it up with
Frank but right now there's just not
enough minutes tonight the strong
bridges is about look how far he comes
from because a wanders just
[Applause]
let's wings that strong that she says
where is my help
gets it over to Tony Parker working
against Nerlens Noel
[Applause]
brothers word follow your shot people
cuz you never know you might get it back
oh my word what a find there by Billy
hello Fitz Carter ever get it wrapped up
Tony Parker is really controlled his
second unit off C's will run a screen
role this time he finds a rookie
[Applause]
and then poor closeout quick assists and
miles between two defenders and lamb
again enjoy the rookies display of
entertainment brought on themselves FK t
Arriba brings it across himself
[Music]
[Applause]
just look at this delivery by M kg in
chest and the sense it let me jump
though I don't think I'm going to jump
trying to exploit something to get to
the other team I know what they like to
do carbon block by Colbert
[Applause]
pensive rebound and look at miles
bridges Rudy Gobert look as soon as he
realizes oh oh that's thick zero coming
at me I'm not going to jump at that one
I'm just gonna give this knowing that
you've got a hot guy behind good
anticipation right there if I leak the
peel away come back for the spiel and
just a quick look ja clock is down at
2:00
[Applause]
setting it down with authority
25:20 our score sacramental on top of
your ordinance
[Music]
[Applause]
Kemba Walker - they all come with a high
percentage fashion for two dunks and
look at that is perfect that ball hit
the backboard the rim a backboard and
Vinnie grab yes oh man the best the best
in the league at the Polka Dot position
at finding ways to put the ball through
the hoop
[Music]
[Applause]
but you gotta have a guy with two hops
that Bob bridges to go up and give it a
one hand draw the attention and gets
behind Harkless clowns coming up 20
points yesterday against Boston quickly
along the pace line my friend Janice
welcome back partner a day but looking
piles go right by a buckle on the poor
close up and just flush it as the law
wrapped is this fly box [ __ ] picture a
woman's bedroom all right
miles bridge is full of fury
oh the Spartan brings it down with two
hands gotta respect his three-point game
right there close down on his left hand
and good the show called pool house
tables back in the day up miles bridge
Oh
so Thunder is real Gutierrez after the
first one he said who you gonna play
through without boots she said by
committee and that's what it's been
weeks monk kicks it back out to bridges
on the baseline
[Applause]
this has been a heck of a lot more
aggressive over the last couple of weeks
why that young rookie this is the Freak
milk on a rebound for Charlotte by miles
bridges here's bridges Simon has made a
business decision
more than likely with the right one so
there's what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content